What’s the problem with science?!?
I’m going to tell you my top 5.
Hey there science fans!
Dr. Kiki from This Week in Science here for
DNews.
I’m used to talking about all the things
that are awe-worthy about science, but science
isn’t perfect.
And, everyone should understand how.
So, here’s my list of the big problems in
scientific research:
Across the board, we lack a complete picture
of the world around us because of a convenience
bias in scientific research.
Typically, researchers are only able to study
animals in the wild when and where animals
are there, and when the scientists have time
to get into the field.
Thanks to an academic research schedule where
researchers are teaching and students are
schooling during a majority of the year, most
research is being carried out during single
seasons rather than year-round.
A recent analysis of over 2000 animal studies
published in major journals over 18 years
found that only 5% of them looked at how multiple
seasons interacted to affect an animal’s
biology.
Additionally, there is a vast over-representation
of male subjects compared to females in the
animal literature.
Because males don’t have babies.
Or, because researchers haven’t collected
enough animals for an analysis to be statistically
significant, studies don’t differentiate
between the sexes at all.
Hopefully, this sex problem will change moving
into the future since the NIH has called for
better balancing of male and female subject
numbers in studies.
While we’re at it, there are still more
men in science than women.
Yes, more and more females are studying in
the sciences than ever before, but the people
in charge are still mainly men.
The culture of the scientific endeavor continues
to favor men, as more men than women are still
hired for academic jobs beyond graduate school,
and more men than women are published in prestigious
journals.
And, the craziest point here, both men and
women in the sciences are to blame as both
sexes favor men two to one in situations like
hiring.
Publication bias
Publication bias is the preference that some
journals show for publishing scientific research
that will be perceived as exciting, will therefore
get cited as a reference by more people, and
be considered impactful.
It turns out that these journals also have
higher retraction rates and publish studies
that are less replicable.
They sure might be exciting to learn about,
but over time as more data gets collected,
high profile studies turn out to be more like
statistical coincidences.
Results bias
The “publish or perish” ethic among scientists
has led to heavy competition to get published
in the leading journals.
Those who do manage to get published can look
forward to many career benefits.
So, it’s not hard to see how with the drive
to publish impactful research, researchers
often overlook negative results that could
be quite informative, or go so far as to cherry-pick
data for their analyses.
Those are extreme examples, but combined with
personal unconscious biases we’re seeing
a large number of retractions in recent years,
and a decline in reproducibility of studies.
Also, scientists who are still trying to cement
their careers are less likely to do studies
that try to replicate the results of others.
There is no glory in being second, even though
it helps the entire scientific community.
All this brings us to how science is funded.
In the US, money can come from either public
or private sources.
Changes to political priorities have left
less than 8% of researchers who apply for
government funding actually receiving it.
Additionally, basic research that could lead
to long-term technological and economic gains
is being underfunded as government grants
emphasize “practical” research with more
immediate and conceivable payoffs.
To make up for shortfalls from public funding,
researchers look for private funding, which
can lead to conflicts of interest that bias
studies.
When the funding just can’t be found, investigators
have to downsize their labs and research efforts.
And, this means less good science being done.
I know all of this sounds pretty bad, but
it can be fixed.
People within the scientific research community
are already working to improve the publication
process, find new solutions to funding scientific
research (like crowd-funding), and remove
human bias from experiments.
My advice to you: Be patient with the process,
continue to be awe-struck by science when
it’s deserved, and always be skeptical of
the extraordinary.
Do you think I missed anything?
What do you think of my list?